this video was made possible by a way
get your away suitcase for $20 off at
the link in the description in the final
days of December 2013 in the small
village of Melly on Duke Guinea
a young 18 month old boy named Emil died
only four days before this child had
been completely healthy acting normally
playing regularly in the bat infested
backyard of his rural home but then he
developed flu-like symptoms which
spiraled and spiraled until he passed
unfortunately such an occurrence is not
uncommon for the young children of
Guinea a country not known for the
quality of its health care but then just
a few days later his sister died too
then his mother then his grandmother
than a family friend each of which had
attended to the boy in his final days
this was not normal but nobody who was
exactly sure what had happened to these
people their symptoms resembled that of
a number of illnesses common to the area
such as malaria and typhoid fever but in
the end the doctor settled on cholera
given this infections profile and
propensity in Guinea but then the
cholera spread now cholera is contagious
so the idea of it spreading is not
surprising but a far higher proportion
of patients than predicted died medical
staff were starting to get concerned
that this might not be just another of
the area's all-too-common cholera
outbreaks and so they password on Tim
it's all self when Tia anglicized as
Doctors Without Borders who were by
chance already on the ground in Guinea
treating a malaria outbreak the
organisation liaised with the infectious
disease experts at their head office in
Geneva
who presented an unsettling hypothesis
they weren't sure but they agreed that
it might not be cholera and then it
might be a bola
the outbreak quite closely followed the
profile of this virus but Ebola had
never really been an issue in West
Africa for the most part it had only
ever been seen in Central Africa what is
now North and South Sudan Uganda the DRC
the Congo and Gabon these current cases
were well over a thousand
from the closest previous outbreak to
the idea of the virus simply randomly
popping up in the middle of the gun and
forest was unlikely but nonetheless
terrifying so they needed to be sure
therefore med sauce on frontier gather
samples pack them in three layers of
protective packaging loaded them on a
plane charter from guaca do flew them to
the capital then transfer them onto the
overnight Air France flight to Paris
where they were analyzed in a
specialized lab unfortunately the worst
of their worst fears were confirmed not
only was the Cibola but it was the sire
strain the most deadly of Ebola species
that confirmation was publicly announced
by the World Health Organization on
March 23rd 2014 nearly three months
after the young boy formally on do died
while the w-h-o was concerned the rest
of the world was not the rest of the
world didn't even realize what was going
on or it's devastating potential the New
York Times for example took four whole
days after the announcement to publish
their first article about the virus 146
word write-up mostly focusing on the
government's ban on bat soup in order to
curb the spread this would be the first
of thousands of articles they would
write over the next few years about this
virus this was the start of the worst
Ebola epidemic in history now that the
virus was identified the goal shifted to
stopping it the organization most in
charge of coordinating the international
response to epidemics is the World
Health Organization the members of this
United Nations agency include a majority
of the world's countries and so when
there's a public health emergency
it falls on them to respond once word
reached the w-h-o their first step was
to activate their global outbreak alerts
and response network this includes
essentially fast response medical teams
for epidemics the first of which in this
case arrived on March 28th just five
days after the initial alert their first
goal was to find the links between the
patients to draw a map of who infected
who in order to try and just quarantine
everyone exposed and stop the virus
before it could even gain its legs this
was not particularly difficult in this
case as the cases in million
attracted attention early on but the
news was also not particularly good you
see when the first victim the young Emil
was sick his mom and sister took him to
stay across the village at his
grandmother's house when that
grandmother later became sick she went
to visit a friend a nurse in the nearby
larger town of greca do in order to get
some help weeks later that nurse too
developed symptoms and sought help from
a friend of his a doctor in the even
larger town of Messiah when that doctor
too fell ill he set off to seek help in
the country's capital but died along the
way and so his body was then sent to the
even larger city of kisi dugu where the
funeral was held now
wala bola does not spread through the
air it does through contact with the
bodily fluids of an infected patient
whether dead or alive so hospitals and
burial facilities are where most
transmissions occur especially if proper
quarantine procedures are not followed
considering that at this point nobody
knew it was a bola nobody was following
these procedures in May Leon do queca do
Musante or KC do GU so with each
infected patient that went to these
cities more and more people were
infected who themselves infected more
and so on and so forth by the time
medical institutions knew this was a
bola three months after the first case
it was too late to trace all the
transmissions the spread was beyond
control therefore focus shifted to
isolating and treating infected the WH o
MSF and other international
organizations shipped in staff by the
planeload not much longer than a week
after detection there were more than a
hundred foreign medical staff in the
country the other important goal was to
ship in as much protective gear as
possible doctors nurses and other
medical staff are at the most risk for
transmission from a bullet patients and
therefore in order to not become
patients themselves they needed to wear
as they became known a bola suits of
which thousands were shipped in within
weeks the country's Ministry of Health
quickly set up a system where if anyone
suspected anyone of having a bola they
could call a hotline one one five for a
doctor to come out on a motorcycle and
investigate if this doctor believed the
patient could indeed have the virus they
would call out a team from MSF which in
full
biohazard suits would transport the
patient to an isolation ward and
hospital in Conakry the capital this
system was quickly overwhelmed with up
to 300 calls a day but it seemed to
actually work by the beginning of May
less than two months after the initial
alert this hospital in Conakry where the
patients were isolated reached its first
week without a new Ebola patient then it
reached its second and its third as
three weeks is the incubation period for
Ebola the period it takes for symptoms
to arise in virus carriers Ament that as
long as nobody in the hospital was
infected the spread would be over with
that preparations began for the retreat
of the NGOs in Guinea
it was crisis averted job well done
mission accomplished until May 27th
that's when a new patient came in and
then more King dozens more from all
around the country it turned out that
the Ebola had not in fact been stopped
but rather many of the patients in the
rural isolated regions of the country
has simply become distrustful of medical
professionals many had seen foreign
medical staff in their towns before they
had seen a bowl of victims and therefore
many came to the conclusion that it was
these staff who were spreading the virus
rather than preventing its spread
therefore when people in these villages
became sick they simply didn't report it
to the country's medical system which
made the problem worse as unprotected
untrained townspeople cared for the
infected well the May of 2014 saw just
74 official cases fewer than each of the
previous two months June saw 290 by June
with the resurgence in cases the world
was now paying attention to Guinea close
by the borders between Guinea Liberia
and Sierra Leone were quickly closed
down but it was too little too late the
virus had spread that June also marked
the first month that both Liberia and
Sierra Leone recorded significant
numbers of cases further afield the rest
of the world wanted to be sure that the
virus would be contained to just these
three countries given that infected
individuals can carry the virus with no
symptoms from 221 days travel was a
your concern most airlines suspended
their flights Emirates stopped flying to
Guinea Delta stop flying to Liberia and
the situation was most pronounced in
Sierra Leone where all airlines except
for Brussels Airlines stopped flying to
the country's airports this lack of
flights to the region made things
difficult in terms of getting supplies
and workers into the region in fact
Brussels Airlines is largely credited
with playing a crucial role in the fight
against the epidemic for having not
canceled their flights the airline
received praise from everyone up to the
Obama administration they flew to Guinea
Liberia and Sierra Leone for the
entirety of the crisis carefully
crafting schedules so that their staff
would never have to spend an overnight
in the Ebola stricken nations passengers
departing on these flights were all
carefully screened to be sure they were
not exhibiting symptoms as Belgium and
the rest of the world certainly did not
want the virus spreading to their
countries and for the most part this
worked well a few isolated cases did
appear in various countries worldwide
mostly from health workers returning
home the epidemic was mostly contained
to Guinea Liberia and Sierra Leone since
the virus's containment was successful
the next step was eradication whence an
individual contracts Ebola there was a
not a whole lot that could be done
medically to stop the virus treatment
essentially involves assuring that an
individual has the fluids and oxygen
necessary for their body to stage the
fight therefore these steps necessary to
reach complete eradication of Ebola in
West Africa
were simple but the implementation was
tough Sensa bola is not contagious until
symptoms arise the key was to just
isolate the infected as soon as symptoms
arose the issue though was that all
three of these countries did not have
the infrastructure necessary to treat
these thousands of cases that came in
each month not only that but in many
cases non-ebola medical facilities
actually closed down in fear of the
virus spreading to their staff meaning
that for unrelated health issues people
were not getting the treatment they
needed all of the international
organizations working in the region
scrambled to set up enough Ebola
treatment centers these didn't mean to
be
at the minimum they could just be tense
but they were crucial to make sure that
the infected patients were not being
turned away from treatment and sent back
to their communities these organizations
confronting the virus each had their own
solution on how to stop the epidemic and
this of course led to disputes
for example the w-h-o held the position
that the best way to rehydrate Ebola
patients a crucial step
given their diarrhea and vomiting was to
administer fluids by IV this
theoretically is true it is more
effective to rehydrate a patient by IV
but MSF meanwhile took a more pragmatic
view saying that in the conditions the
most effective route was to have
patients drink rehydration solution you
see medical staff confined to thick
protective clothing could only work for
about an hour at a time in the West
African age therefore there was almost
always a shortage of medically qualified
staff and according to the MSF stance
there just weren't enough resources to
set up and monitor all the patients IVs
so in the end they were actually getting
less fluids overall all the different
organizations working in the region it
took their own stance on this debate as
nobody could reach a conclusion on
theory versus pragmatism and given the
variety of external variables
retrospective studies today cannot even
confidently conclude who was right by
October 2014 bed capacity exceeded
demand and so for the most part there
was no longer an issue of turning
patients away the other main concern in
terms of containing the virus was the
proper handling of the deceased as even
after death the virus can spread
cremation would have been by far the
safest option but in the cultures of
most of the affected places this method
of handling the dead is quite taboo
Liberia briefly required the cremation
of victims much of the disdain of his
citizens but elsewhere specialized teams
assured the safe burial of the infected
a practice going against the culture of
extensive ceremonial burials in the
region but at this point in October 2014
nobody really knew whether they were at
the beginning middle or end of
epidemic nobody could be really sure how
effective the efforts had been an
estimate made by the American CDC at
this point estimated the worst case
scenario as 1.4 million infected by
January 2015
October 2014 with six thousand nine
hundred and eighty seven cases of Ebola
was a by far the worst month of the
epidemic mercifully though the worst
case scenario did not come true month by
month cases dropped as patient isolation
community engagement and safe burial
proved effective on May 9th 2015 barely
a year after the epidemic started its
exponential growth the World Health
Organization published its momentous
message the Ebola outbreak in Liberia is
over more than a month had passed since
the last confirmed case meaning further
transmission was improbable that same
message came soon after for Guinea and
Sierra Leone and by the new year 2016
Ebola was aside from a few small future
flare-ups eradicated in West Africa
quite soon after the statistics came in
twenty eight thousand six hundred and
fifty two infected and eleven thousand
three hundred and twenty five dead in
what was the worst Ebola outbreak in
history unfortunately though history is
now repeating itself
on July 17th 2019 the director-general
of the World Health Organization
announced that he had declared the
ongoing Ebola epidemic in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo a public health
emergency of international concern the
same highest level of w-h-o emergency
declared for the West African epidemic
five years ago about two years ago I ran
the first away sponsorship on this
channel I already like their suitcase
when I first got it but since then I've
traveled with mine to five continents a
total of well over a hundred thousand
miles and I can now confidently say that
I love it all their suitcases include
tons of features like a tsa approved
lock removable laundry bag built-in
compression system super smooth 300
degrees spinner wheels and their
carry-on bags even include an injectable
battery to charge your devices even as I
write this video I'm currently traveling
around you
up with her check back the newest one of
mine will that carry on away bag I have
is back at home still in great shape
after hundreds of thousands of miles of
travel if you need a suitcase away bags
are just an incredible value for the
quality they are and since they have
lifetime warranties they will be the
last two cases you ever buy the decision
is made easier for you by two facts that
they have a 100 day unconditional trial
period and that by going to away travel
calm / wind / 20 and using the code wind
/ 20 you will get $20 off your first
order